hey everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today we are diving into the
world of lead generation strategies the
game changer for businesses looking to
supercharge their growth but before we
jump in did you know that a recent
survey found that a whooping 73% of
businesses consider lead generation
their top marketing priority Yes you
heard it right 73% so if you have been
wondering how to harness the power of
lead generation you are in the right
place in this video first up we will
understand what lead generation is all
about next we will break down the
process step by step lastly we'll
explore effective lead generation
strategies to propel your business
forward whether you're a Season Pro or a
new to the game this video has got you
covered let's jump in and master the art
of lead generation together also if you
are interested in advancing your career
consider per University postgraduate
program in digital marketing this
comprehensive program offers
certification as a digital marketer
through live Interactive Learning dive
deep into fundamental and advanced
digital marketing strategies utilizing
Harvard Business publishing cases and 20
plus Hands-On projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
chat GPT and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources all right so
without further Ado let's get started
with the first topic so what is lead
generation a lead is just someone who
has shown interest in your business in
simple terms anyone who has shared their
contact details with you for example to
join a webinar get a free guide or
subscribe to a newsletter is considered
as a lead this is because they have
interacted with their Business website
and allowed you to reach out to them now
lead generation is the process of
attracting and collecting information
from potential customers who have shown
interest in your products or Services it
involves strategies and activities to
capture the attention of individuals who
may be interested in what your business
offers the goal is to turn the these
interested individuals or leads to
customers by nuturing the relationship
and guiding through the sales funnel
lead generation methods can include
various marketing efforts the aim is to
build a pool of potential customers that
can be further engaged and converted
into loyal clients for your business so
this was about lead generation now let's
understand the process of lead
generation so lead generation involves
multiple steps this process guides
potential customers from initial
interest to becoming a value leads for
business growth first one is research
before attempting to gather leads it's
crucial to gather as much information
about your target audience understand
not only who they are but also their
location priorities and especially their
immediate challenges next one is
creating your personal personas creating
customer personas can be helpful
outlining typical customer details like
demographics budget and requirements
consider factors like social habits
professional background Etc after
identify your target audience pinpoint
where they usually engage do they use
Facebook actively or are they more
responsive to email communication what
sets apart your product or service from
theirs and importantly what makes your
Superior so these all things you'll have
to take care about next one is create
great content yes at this point you
should be aware of the problems your
product solves for potential customers
utilize the knowledge to make content
that addresses those issues consider the
platform you're using as as it impacts
the type of content you can share for
instance videos are effective on social
media but you cannot include directly
them into the mail so if your audience
is on Twitter keep in mind that long
blogs might need to be linked or
shortened always prioritize providing
value ensuring each piece of content
serves a particular purpose all right
now the next one is lead generation
database you might have the best
potential customers but it won't help
unless you manage them properly it's
it's essential to set up a database to
keep track of and analyze sort and group
your potential customers consider using
an automated CRM system to make this
process much easier these systems often
let you categorize leads by type and the
level of Interest this helps your sales
team go through their list more
effectively so this was about the
process of lead generation now let's
have a look at its strategies all right
so lead generation
strategies so first one on the list is
create landing pages that are
straightforward create simple and easy
to understand landing pages choose
straightforward designs that focus on
Clarity use plain language to deliver
your message so visitors quickly
understand without getting confused get
rid of any unnecessary complications to
make their experience smooth and user
friendly pick a clean layout without
extra things that might distract make
sure to have a clear call to action to
guide visitors effectively embracing
simply licity creates a friendly online
space makes users more engaged and
leaving a positive impression the main
aim is to make information easy to
understand for everyone no matter their
level of knowledge all right now the
next one is craft more effective
advertisement so this is the second
strategy so make your ads better by
creating interesting content that people
can easily understand use simple words
and attractive pictures to share your
message talk about the most important
good things your product or service off
offers don't make it too complicated or
include too much information your ad
should be clear and easy to get even if
someone just looks at it quickly try
different versions of your ad to see
what people like best listen to what
customers say and make changes if needed
a good ad makes its Point quickly and
stays in people's mind keep it clear and
related to what people care about to
make your ads work better all right now
coming to the next one that is generate
plenty of opportunity for optins yes
create lot of chances for people to sign
up on your website use webinars free
reports and live demos to get users
interested don't just stick to a couple
of signups options turn every blog post
into a chance for people to join give
away things like recipes PDF versions of
blog post worksheets and resource guides
move the signup box from the sidebar and
use popups to grab attention make users
decide by using clear popup messages the
idea is to offer many appealing
opportunities for people to connect with
content and offerings this helps more
people to get involved and expand your
potential audience all right now coming
to the next one which is remarketing
remarketing lets you reconnect with
website visitors across the Internet by
tagging users you can reappear in
various online spaces like email YouTube
and Google this strategy enhances the
impact of your overall marketing efforts
such as content and social media
marketing it brings your startup back to
the tension of the potential customers
reinforcing your band presence in
essence remarketing acts as a friendly
reminder ensuring that your audience
doesn't forget about your products or
Services while they engage in their
online activities it's an effective way
to stay on the radar and maximize the
impact of your marketing Endeavors all
right so the next one is Gmail ads so
Gmail ads offer a important way to
connect with your desired audience
particularly advantageous for SAS
startups these ads provide a unique
opportunity to engage with a highly
valuable demographics your competitors
customers through Gmail ads you can
precisely aim your AdWords campaign
ensuring it reaches individuals who
actively receive emails from your
competitors this target approach grants
you direct access to a pool of potential
customers already familiar with the
comparable products increasing the
likelihood of converting them it's a
strategic way to tap into a readymade
market leveraging the power of
competition to expand your reach and
potentially your users of similar
services to explore what your startup
has to offer all right the next one on
the list is free trials so many
individuals hesitate to share their
email addresses fearing unwanted spam
this possess a challenge for businesses
to address this concern offering
something valuable in exchange for
contact information is a key utilize
risk-free trials or discount codes as
portent tools to overcome sales
obstacles once prospects experience your
product or service retarget them with
ending offers to boost conversions
providing a free gift a coupon or the
opportunity to test your product can
significantly increase the number of
people willing to share their
information this approach not only
captures leads but also builds trust and
increases the likelihood of turning
potential customers into satisfied ones
so these were some of the strategies of
lead generation we have understood the
mysteries of lead generation from
understanding its concept to breaking
down the process and exploring effective
strategies now equipped with these
insights it's your turn to make a mark
in the world of lead generation if you
found this video valuable don't forget
to like And subscribe and share feel
free to drop any comments or thoughts in
the comment section below keep earning
those lead generation skills and we'll
catch you in the next video Until Then
happy generating and take care staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here